hey what is up guys i'm kphd here and
samsung came out with two different
versions of its flagship android phone
this year the galaxy s6 and then the
galaxy s6 edge which you've probably
heard a lot about the regular galaxy s6
i reviewed as its own standalone phone
it's great and a lot of ways it's one of
the best phones you can buy but then the
edge is as the name implies a little bit
physically different it has a curve over
the edge of both sides of the glass and
that costs a hundred dollars more for
this version so you better get something
out of it so what exactly do you get for
100 bucks internally these phones are
identical so they're the same phone same
chip same ram same camera same
everything objectively the only real
difference between them is the display
and the dimensions so the galaxy s6 edge
is a tiny bit thicker than the regular
s6 it's seven millimeters thick and
actually houses a slightly larger
battery a 2600 milliamp hour battery so
not a huge difference but you know worth
noting the biggest difference though
from the build comes with the feel in
the hand so since the glass wraps around
the sides of the phone and sort of
extends the display a bit in an
immersive way it also means you get less
of a side of the phone to hold on to
when you're using it and this is
something you find out more and more as
you're using the phone but i found if i
grip the phone the wrong way or squeeze
it at all i would actually start
clicking things on the screen by
accident but if i was too careful to not
touch the screen at all then you're
basically just holding on to a sharp
metal edge and that actually got
uncomfortable after a while there's
significantly less material to hold on
the sides and because of the angles and
the way it's built you're really not
holding onto a metal side you're holding
onto a metal rail to pick up and hold
the phone
it does make the phone look and feel
super thin and it is eye-catching
believe me but this turned into a case
of feeling like a little bit too thin
now samsung does build in some neat
software features to take advantage of
the new shape so it's not as extreme as
the curve on the note 4 edge which is
only on one side
but this is a little bit more convenient
here since you can choose which side any
of these features show up on so you get
edge lighting for incoming calls people
edge for a quick swipe in to contact
your favorite people information stream
to show notifications and info on the
edge and the night clock
i found the night clock and the
information stream to actually make the
most sense since they take advantage of
the oled display and only light the edge
pixels when you have them in use so they
don't waste any battery but they're
actually the features that i use the
least because i just never felt
compelled to use them even though i feel
like they'd be very easy to use but the
ones i did use are the people edge and
the edge lighting they're very cool so i
have a few favorite contacts available
and you can swipe in from well only the
home screen you can pull in that tab
from the home screen at any time to
contact them and you can see they have a
little ring around their picture with a
color and you gotta remember these
colors from again contact these people
anytime they contact me they're
associated with that color so if i miss
a call from one of them i get a sort of
a side notification in addition to the
one up top that gives me info on that
missed call
from one of my favorite contacts and it
lets me ping them back if i want to
right from there it's nothing you
couldn't do with a regular screen but
having the curve there makes this feel
more natural and any incoming call from
a favorite contact while your phone is
face down on the table will light up the
edges with that phone's uh that contact
color so you know who it is before you
pick it up the funny thing is i didn't
want to put this all glass phone face
down on a table that often but it was a
nice thing to see it work uh but that's
about it for the edge specific features
everything else about that edge display
is just aesthetics just the crazy way it
looks people really like this apps
suddenly feel a lot more immersive when
it feels like there's no bezel at all
content and images just sort of spill
over the sides of the phone with no
barrier and the fact that it's curved
makes a lot of the swiping more pleasant
too you know all the the new apps with
the new drawer that swipe in from the
side especially all the good google apps
that will be more comfortable to use
because of this curve this is probably a
great phone for tinder with all that
swiping so yeah it's just not an
aesthetically unique thing but it
actually has a little bit of benefit
over the everyday use
the one thing to watch out for is glare
and distortion again since it's a curve
uh if it weren't curved we would just be
saying this is a phone with zero side
bezel but the curve introduces a little
bit of glare problems that the regular
galaxy s6 doesn't have to worry about i
mean there's almost no position that you
can hold the edge and not get any glare
from somewhere and there's also a little
bit of light fall off on the far edges
with the curve and then yeah distortion
can be a factor with full screen media
too you'll notice that so long story
short when i was introduced to both the
phones the galaxy s6 edge and the
regular galaxy s6 i really like the edge
version a lot more but this is one of
those cases where the initial impression
is a little bit different from the final
verdict i originally said the galaxy s6
edge could be its own standalone phone
and the regular galaxy s6 is a sort of a
backup in case this doesn't work but now
because it's 100 extra it's sort of a
different case and as cool as it is the
edge screen probably isn't worth the
extra 100 to most people it does look
really cool on a table and in the hand
and it does seem a lot thinner and a lot
different and it does differentiate
itself from a normal phone but when you
consider the price difference it's a
little harder to justify maybe we'll see
edge versions of samsung phones that
aren't a full hundred dollars more than
their regular counterparts in the future
but until then i'd say hold off even
though it looks pretty awesome thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
the next one
peace